Grafica una recta que tenga una pendiente
positiva y menor que la pendiente de azul.
Ahora, vamos a pensar por un segundo,
qué significa, pendiente.
Si tú escuchas la palabra pendiente en tu
vida cotidiana, seguramente te estás refiriendo
a que tan inclinado está algo, por ejemplo,
la pendiente de una pista de esquí.
Así por ejemplo, esta recta que tenemos aquí
de color naranja, no está nada inclinada,
está plana, así que decimos que tiene una
pendiente de 0.
Otra forma de verlo es, si "x" aumenta, entonces
¿qué le pasa a "y"?
Bueno, te puedes dar cuenta que "y" no cambia,
por lo tanto, esta recta tiene una pendiente de 0.
Ahora, si la recta de naranja la movemos un
poco de esta forma... vamos a moverla, algo así...
Bueno, entonces tiene una pendiente positiva,
¿por qué?
Tú te puedes dar cuenta que cuando"x" vale -5,
"y" vale 5 y ahora que nosotros nos movimos
a, supongamos para acá...
cuando "x" vale 5, "y"vale, en este caso 8.
Por lo tanto, cuando "x" aumenta,
"y" también aumenta.
Lo que quiere decir que esta recta tiene una
pendiente positiva.
Ahora, si nosotros movemos este punto a un
poco más para arriba, bueno entonces tenemos
una pendiente más positiva y ahora nos movemos
un poco más para arriba, tenemos una pendiente
más grande y si ahora nos movemos hasta por
acá, bueno tenemos una pendiente mucho más grande,
porque quiero que te des cuenta que cuando "x" aumenta, "y" aumenta de una manera muy rápida.
Nos estamos moviendo hacia arriba de una
manera muy muy rápida
y por lo tanto tenemos una pendiente muy muy positiva.
Ahora, aquí tenemos una pendiente menos positiva,
aquí una pendiente menos positiva,
aquí una menos positiva y bueno, podríamos jalar
éste para acá y decir que tenemos una pendiente de 0,
y si nosotros movemos, ahora, esta recta para acá,
date cuenta que tenemos una pendiente negativa,
porque cuando "x" aumenta, "y" está
disminuyendo, por ejemplo,
si ponemos justo aquí este punto.
En este punto, "x" vale -6 y "y" vale 8 y
después de que "x" aumenta hasta 6,
entoncesel valor de "y" baja hasta 6, por lo tanto
la pendiente es negativa, porque "y" está decreciendo.
Fíjate que aunque "x" está creciendo, "y"
está disminuyendo.
Por lo tanto, esta es una pendiente negativa.
Pero ahora, lo que a nosotros nos piden es
graficar una recta que tenga una pendiente
que sea positiva y menor que la pendiente
de la recta azul.
Si te das cuenta,
la recta  azul tiene una pendiente positiva,
porque cuando "x" aumenta, "y"también aumenta.
Por ejemplo aquí, cuando "x" toma valores
negativos, bueno pues tenemos un valor también
negativo en "y" y después cuando "x" toma
unos valores positivos,
"y" toma también algunos valores positivos.
Por lo tanto, está aumentando "x" y aumentando "y",
lo que quiere decir que la recta de azul
tiene una pendiente positiva.
Pero ahora, nos están pidiendo que esta recta
de naranja, tenga una pendiente que sea positiva
y en primer lugar, esta pendiente no es positiva.
Por lo tanto, aquí tenemos una pendiente
de 0 y si nos bajamos para acá, tenemos una
pendiente positiva, pero lo que queremos es
que sea menor que la pendiente de la recta azul.
Si te das cuenta, aquí tenemos una pendiente
menor que esta recta de azul, por acá tenemos
una pendiente muy grande y por lo tanto tenemos
una pendiente mayor que la recta de azul y bueno,
si nosotros retrocedemos, por aquí
tenemos casi la misma pendiente y en este
caso tenemos una pendiente que es positiva,
pero es menor que esta recta de azul,
entonces se vería más o menos así.
Así que recuerda, si quieres tener una pendiente
de 0, entonces estaríamos justo por acá...
quieres tener una pendiente negativa entonces
estaríamos como por acá,
pero nosotros lo que queremos
es una pendiente positiva
y que sea menor que la pendiente de esta recta de azul.
Y por lo tanto, ésta, sería una de las formas en la que tenemos la respuesta que nosotros estamos buscando.
Y por lo tanto, es hora de comprobar respuesta...
Y correcto, ya está.